hello everyone welcome to the screen
recorded lectures for advanced mechanics
of solids so these are some special
lectures are instituting the Coe with 19
I hope everyone is staying safe taking
all precautionary measures if you
remember I had discussed earlier while
we were our classes were going on that I
would be discussing a couple of
relatively easier topics near the end of
the semester so here we are so the topic
that we are going to discuss will be
relatively easier than the earlier
topics are not going to say that this is
easy by any way but it is definitely
easier than the previous topics
particularly because we are not going to
take recourse to any of the variational
formulation that we had been using
earlier so it will be basically building
on top on on the concepts that we had
learned during our undergraduate days so
the first topic one of this relatively
easy topics is the unsymmetric bending
of beams
all right in certain textbooks this
particular topics is is also referred to
as skew bending of beams so on symmetric
or skewed okay the moment we heard this
topic the name of this topic unsymmetric
bending of beams the first natural
question which should which should come
to your mind is that if we are going to
study on symmetric bending of beams then
does it mean that all this while all
throughout our undergraduate days and
during the first half of this course
when we were studying the bending of
beams where we really studying the
symmetric bending of beams the answer to
this that question is yes we had been
studying all along the symmetric bending
of beams so this topic is something
definitely new but we are going to build
on previous concepts so what is what is
different what is so much
what is the unsymmetric part here so
let's look at that first in a very very
qualitative fashion we will develop the
mathematical framework a little bit
later so you know going back to our
undergraduate discussions what we
usually did back then was to consider a
beam in this fashion so we always drew
the beam like this
in order to keep the picture simple I
will avoid drawing the supports but I
hope you all understand that this beam
is not just hanging in here there are
definitely supports here at this end and
this end I'm not going to draw it okay
so what we usually did was to consider
some kind of loading the most common was
some kind of a point loading like this
there could be more than one point load
of course or we considered some kind of
distributed loading like this it's not
necessary that we have uniformly
distributed load but just to keep things
simple I'm drawing it as uniformly
distributed load now from the front view
of this diagram no question of symmetry
or on symmetry appears but it will
appear if we consider the cross section
of the beam under consideration so if we
look at the cross section from this end
the most common cross section that we
had been considering during our
undergraduate days was a rectangular
cross section so it was something like
this
this was the most common commonly
considered cross section now immediately
by looking at this cross section we can
identify that it is a doubly symmetric
cross section meaning that both about
the horizontal axis meaning something
like this as well as the vertical axis
this particular cross section is
perfectly symmetric now the symmetry
that we are that I mentioned as far as
our undergraduate studies was concerned
has definitely do with this symmetry of
the cross section but it also has to do
with the nature of the loading that was
used so if I draw a three dimensional
version of this diagram what will what
it will look like is something like this
so let's have our beam like this
so here we have the rectangular
cross-section
now as I mentioned earlier this is
definitely a beam having a cross-section
cross-section which is doubly symmetric
but it is also important to note that
for the kind of formula that we are used
to be applying from our undergraduate
days the loading that we used was
supposed to be something like this so
suppose we had our y-axis in this
fashion and z-axis in this fashion where
we note that the y axis coincides with
the vertical axis of symmetry of the
rectangular cross section and the z axis
coincides with the horizontal axis of
symmetry of this rectangular cross
section so the origin actually lies at
the centroid of this rectangular cross
section and we will discuss in more
detail about the centroid and centroidal
axis later on now coming back to the
load what is important to note here is
this particular distributed load that I
have drawn here it is not just
arbitrarily placed on the top of this
beam rather it is arranged to be loaded
in this fashion
the load is acting vertically downward
but it is also passing or it is it is
coinciding at this end with the y-axis
that is with the vertical axis of
symmetry so this load is very much
vertically symmetric for this particular
beam so this was the so the symmetry
that we were talking about for from our
undergraduate days so let me write this
down clearly this thing this thing this
is the case of symmetric bending of
beams
so when we want to talk about the
unsymmetric bending of beams what is
different what is different is that we
have to consider two possibilities the
first possibility is that the doubly
symmetric cross section that we had that
we are considering here this remains so
even though we consider an symmetric
bending of beams the cross section
itself remains something like this it's
still perfectly doubly symmetric but the
loading is no longer like this so if we
load the beam through some uniformly
distributed load or some kind of
distributed load or some kind of point
load but it is not arranged to be
passing through the vertical axis of
symmetry of the beam then we no longer
have the symmetric bending of beams so
that is the first possibility so let me
go to the new page to a new page and
draw that clearly
the cross-section
is symmetric
just like before but loading is
unsymmetric
so we can easily Depok that in a
three-dimensional configuration in this
fashion so we again draw the rectangular
cross-section this is our beam we can
draw our y axis and the z axis
which coincide respectively with the
vertical axis of symmetry and the
horizontal axis of symmetry of the
rectangular cross-section but this time
the loading is in a different way so
so you can see here clearly that the
loading makes a certain angle with the
y-axis we still have a uniformly
distributed load I have chosen in that
way I might as well have a point load
but this is no longer coinciding the
line of action of this of this load is
no longer coinciding with the vertical
axis of symmetry and certainly not with
the horizontal axis of symmetry also so
this is very much a case of unsymmetric
bending the next case and the second
case of unsymmetric bending that is
possible is where the cross section
itself does not have any symmetry so
so we'll have something a cross-section
which is somewhat of this fashion some
kind of an irregular geometry so if we
have a beam like this no matter what
kind of loading you impose on this this
is going to be an unsymmetrical bending
all right so what we are going to do is
to study the second case we are going to
study the second case that's because if
we can develop the mathematical
framework to cover this particular case
of unsymmetric bending this is the more
complicated case compared to this one
then this first case can easily be
derived from this second case and as a
special case of that mathematical
framework the symmetric bending of beams
can very well be derived also so if we
can have a framework for this everything
is covered so that's our plan but before
we can launch into the direct
development of that plan of that
mathematical framework for the
unsymmetric bending of beams having some
kind of an irregular unsymmetric
cross-section we need to briefly brush
up on some of the very preliminary
concepts associated with bending of
beams so what we want to discuss first
of all is the concepts associated with
centroid centroidal axis principal axis
and the all-important
topic of neutral axis okay
so let us go to a new page and start
discussing these preliminary concepts
so suppose we have
cross-section like this which obviously
doesn't have any any symmetry and we set
up our coordinate axis arbitrarily in
this fashion
then refer to this to these coordinate
access our centroid will be calculated
in this fashion or the coordinates of
the centroid will be calculated in this
fashion so this is the definition of the
centroid coordinates the y-coordinate
will be given by
this formula integration yda by a where
this capital a denotes the area of cross
section area of the cross section the Z
coordinate of the centroid will be given
by this formula and you can immediately
see that this is not too different from
the way that the center of masses are
defined the only difference is that the
density is not present here on the right
hand side okay now let's say that as a
result of this calculation the Y bar and
the Z bar they come out to be somewhere
here so let's say this is y bar z bar
now suppose next what we do is we
consider this very same cross section
but we shift our coordinate axis the
origin of our coordinate axis to this Y
bar z bar so what I want to do is
is to consider
and access a pair of axes like this y -
Z - note that the origin of this y - Z -
coordinate system lies at Y bar z bar
refer to the Y Z system now in this y -
Z - system what do you think would be
the formula for the centroid coordinates
it will be nothing but zero
this and zero
this I believe this should be clear to
everyone so I could have written this on
the left hand side as y dash bar and Z
dash bar but that but I know that that
will be nothing but the centroid itself
and since the centroid is a property
which is directly connected with the
geometry so it has nothing to do with
the choice of the coordinate system so
the y dash bar and the Z dash bar are
nothing but 0 and 0 all right now
what is important to note here is that
this particular coordinate axis y dash
and Z dash because they pass through the
centroid of the cross section under
consideration they will be referred to
as centroidal axis
now we must not have any impression that
this why - must be parallel to the
original y axis and the z - must be
parallel to the original z axis we might
as well have a pair of centroidal axis
which is like this
so why - y double dash is a double dash
are also centroidal axis
okay when we develop our concepts later
on we'll be repeatedly referring to
centroidal axis and the centroid so it
is important to remember this particular
page the next topic that we'll brush up
is the has to do with principal axis so
let's go to a new page
before we can discuss principle axis we
have to first of all recap the concept
of the second moment of area or rather
the definitions of the second moment of
area
in our undergraduate textbooks this
particular term the second moment of
area is sometimes referred to as the
moment of inertia I'm sure most of you
know this already
so just to recap for a cross-section
where for a cross-section which is which
looks like this some arbitrary
cross-section and where the coordinate
axes are like this
sorry I don't need the cashier and just
skipped it as y&z
the second moment of area can be of
three kinds the first one I Y is defined
as integration of Z square da integrated
over the entire area
I said defined as integration of Y
square DM and Y z iy said which is
defined as integration of Y Z da so
these are all definitions so we might as
well denote it clearly like this fashion
so this colon with the equal to sign it
denotes that these are definitions we
are choosing to define it like this I
personally do not like this term the
moment of inertia very much not
particularly fond of this because the
moment we write something like inertia I
have an intuitive feeling that this must
have something to do with the mass but
please note here that this is purely a
geometrical property here this iy I said
I wise it just like the centroidal
concept the the centroid concept there
is a purely geometrical concept it has
nothing to do with the mass it has it it
has it has some or it has a direct
resemblance with the moment of inertia
that we study in high school physics but
it is certainly not that any way for
historical purposes many textbooks still
refer to these things as moments of
inertia
now to go back to the question of what
our principal axis we have to understand
first of all that the values of I why
the values of iy i z + iy zed depend
very much on our choice of the y axis
and the z axis so if we keep on maybe
rotating this y&z axis maybe shifting
the origin of this thing the values of i
why i said and i said are definitely
going to change now if it so happens
that we choose our y and z axis in such
a fashion that the value of i wiser
turns out to be 0 then in that
particular case the y axis and the z
axis will be referred to as the
principal axis so let me repeat that as
we keep on changing the orientation and
the position of the y axis and the z
axis the values of iy i said and i wise
it will keep on changing if we end up
with such a orientation and position of
y and z axis such that the value of the
iy z is equal to 0 then in that
particular case the y axis and the z
axis will be referred to as the
principal axis so let me write the down
quickly
now it is interesting to note that when
we have such a situation that I why's
that is equal to zero it also so happens
that the values of iy and I said take on
external values so one of them is a
maximum the other is a minimum so it is
it's of course possible to prove this
mathematically but we are not going to
go down that route you can draw some
analogy with the 2-dimensional state of
stress that we studied during our
undergraduate days and where we said
that if we have a state of stress given
by Sigma xx Sigma YY and Sigma X Y the
principal stresses would be given in
that situation where the Sigma X Y is
equal to 0 in a similar fashion here
also when I wise it is equal to 0 the iy
and the I said they correspond to
principal axis so as a little thought
exercise try to think about what would
be the value of iy said for a cross
section like this there
the access are in this fashion for a
cross section like this
where the axes are like this
and
in this particular situation
the next preliminary concept that we are
going to brush up is the extremely
extremely important concept of neutral
axis so let me go to a new page and
discuss that
so I believe we all have a fairly good
idea for the neutral axis is
nevertheless considering the extreme
importance of this concept let us write
down its definition in words
so the axis in a cross-section
along which the
bending stresses
our zero it is very very important that
we note that this is the axis the
neutral axis the axis in a cross section
so what do we mean by this so let us go
back very briefly to to the
consideration of a symmetric bending of
beam and note that the picture is
somewhat like this so we have the beam
cross-section
in this way and
the neutral axis in this way let me draw
that again
there's a little bit tilted still so
I'll try that again
okay I think I'm happy with that I'll
try to draw the stress distribution on
this exactly falling from what we
learned during our undergraduate days so
okay so
the picture that I am thinking of is
where the cross-section of the beam
which is above the neutral axis so if
this dashed line represents my neutral
axis the part which is above it is under
tensile stress or if I imagine that in
which case the bottom part would be
under compression or if I consider the
other way around that the top part is
under compressive stress then the bottom
part would be under tensile stress so
let me draw the latter so the top part I
denote by a compressive stress
and the bottom part by tensile
okay I'm fairly happy with that picture
and we of course understand that the
beam is here
so this picture is relatively a simple
picture although I took a fairly long
time to draw it there's a fairly simple
picture that we have from our
undergraduate days and this is the case
of a symmetric bending of beam I think I
didn't draw one line here
okay
so as I was saying this is the case of
symmetric bending of beams nevertheless
even from this consideration of of a
symmetric bending of beams we can learn
a lot the first thing to note is that
this this neutral axis as the definition
says this axis is in the cross-section
this is very important to note this is
my cross section this is my under beam
but I am only concerned with a
particular cross section when I'm
talking about the neutral axis so some
textbooks they denote the neutral axis
to be something like this
so when you are looking at the beam from
the front the projection of this neutral
axis as you consider different cross
sections along the beam along the length
of the beam that is what they refer to
as the neutral axis but but that is
wrong I don't want to consider that as
that as my neutral axis so I will remove
this
this dashed line so this dashed line
that is within the cross-section that is
my neutral axis okay now this is a very
elementary concept when we are talking
about the symmetric bending of beams but
even when we go up to unsymmetric
bending of beams we can build on this
concept how so we have already seen that
in the case of unsymmetric bending of
beams especially the second case that we
are going to consider when not even the
cross section will be symmetric and and
certainly the the nature of the load
will not matter if the cross section of
the beam itself is unsymmetric even in
that difficult case there will be an
axis passing through the or in the cross
section where the bending stresses will
be zero it will not be such a nice
horizontal line but it will be there
there will be a certain line in the
cross section where the bending stresses
will be zero and that will be the
starting point or that will be the
connecting bridge between the concepts
between our undergraduate concepts and
the concept set that we are going to
develop now so in connection with this
neutral axis there is a very interesting
point I mean it's such a nice and clean
point that we can almost write it like a
theorem and this theorem says that as
long as a beam is subjected
- pure bending and this is very
important so as long as a beam is
subjected to pure bending the neutral
axis will always always pass through the
centroid of a cross-section so let me
write that down
so this little statement can very easily
be proven starting from the from the
consideration that what we are
considering is pure bending which is to
say that there are no axial forces
acting on the beam
so no axial forces
so connected to this point under pure
bending we have zero axial forces and
that means
now it will be fairly easy for us to
understand what we have just written if
we quickly refer to the diagram on our
left so that is this diagram but the
good thing about this statement is that
it will be true even if we considered
unsymmetric bending but first let us
understand it here so let me just
quickly denote my coordinate axis
so see what I have done here is I've
written it as y-axis and the z-axis is
coinciding with the neutral axis now
because we are accustomed to seeing this
picture we may say that what is the
point of trying to prove this because we
can clearly see that the neutral axis is
very much in a symmetric position in
this diagram which means that the
neutral axis is surely passing through
the centroid and we have taken the z
axis also part to be coinciding with
this so everything is perfect here but
as I said what we are going to develop
here will be also be pertaining to a
very general situation so let us pretend
for the sake of a deeper understanding
that this neutral axis is there but we
do not know that this neutral axis is
passing through the centroid of this
rectangular cross-section so we are
going to pretend that this neutral axis
here is not going to pass or we do not
know that it is going to pass through
the centroid of this rectangular
cross-section so there is some value in
trying to prove what we are going to
prove here okay so the next step of the
proof is where we use the famous Hookes
law sorry I don't want this color
to write the Sigma X's xx as Young's
modulus times epsilon xx now because we
have studied applied elasticity in the
previous semester and we have been we
have grown accustomed to writing the
Sigma xx in a fairly complicated fashion
where we may have dependence on epsilon
YY and epsilon said said but you please
note that here when we are considering
the bending of beams we are implicitly
working under the under the limitations
of the euler-bernoulli beam hypothesis
and within that Euler Bernoulli beam
hypothesis we do not allow for any
strains along the Y direction or the Z
direction we are only considering
strains which are normal to the cross
section so we are only considering the
possibility of length changes along the
longitudinal axis of the beam next as an
oft-repeated step we are going to
represent the epsilon X X in terms of Y
and the radius of curvature so I believe
I have already discussed this particular
result in class earlier so we need to
put a minus here so epsilon X X is equal
to minus y divided by capital R where R
is the radius of curvature of the beam
under consideration okay so
the Youngs modulus is a constant under
pure bending the radius of curvature
does not change so what we can do is we
can we can take the Youngs modulus and
the r out of this integration and what
we'll have is basically this
and this shows us that what we wanted to
prove has actually already come out so
let's take a let's recap what we have
actually done here we we wrote the Sigma
X X using the Hookes law as Young's
modulus times the epsilon xx we
represented the epsilon xx in terms of
the y by r and then we obtained this
thing now one may question how does this
show that the neutral axis is passing
through the centroid well you see here
in this diagram referring to this
diagram the Y is being calculated
referred to the z axis so the y
coordinate is the y coordinate of any
point which is here so this is the
direction Y that means that the z axis
and please note that the z axis is
coinciding with the neutral axis so this
thing is actually has to pass through
the centroid because you see the y da
integration integration of yd equal to
zero this the integration Y da is
nothing but very much a part of
of our definition of the centroid so if
you remember it from earlier we had
written it like the y coordinate of the
centroid was defined like this
so if integration y da is equal to zero
it means that because capital a is
nonzero the y bar has to be zero and the
y bar has to be zero means
the centroid is actually lying on the z
axis which means that because the
neutral axis is coinciding with the z
axis because the neutral axis is
coinciding with the z axis here the
centroid must lie on the neutral axis or
the neutral axis is passing through the
centroid which is what we wanted to
prove all right now this was in
reference to the to the case of
symmetric bending but this same concept
will apply very much even if we consider
an symmetric bending of beams so as I
had said earlier even if we have a
completely irregular cross section with
no symmetry whatsoever we can have a
bending of beam that will of course be a
non symmetric bending of beam but in
that case also we'll end up there will
be a neutral axis along which the
bending stresses will be zero and it is
guaranteed that that bending stress or
sorry that neutral axis will pass
through the centroid of the cross
section provided we are considering a
case of pure bending so with these
considerations this brush-up of the
preliminary ideas under our belt we can
launch directly into a discussion of
unsymmetric bending of beams and the
development of the formula associated
with that so we'll start doing that from
the next page
okay so we'll consider a a general cross
section like this and we'll set up
coordinate axis in this fashion
so this is my y-axis and this is my z
axis
what I will note here very importantly
is that because this is an irregular
cross section there is no symmetry here
and which means that as you can clearly
see also this y-axis is certainly not an
inverted vertical axis of symmetry the z
axis is certainly not any fun and
relaxed source of symmetry these are
just some arbitrary chosen mutually
perpendicular coordinate axis but one
may question that is in a specific
choice about this origin the answer is
yes what I want to do is I want to place
this origin at the centroid of this
cross section the reason is I want that
I want the neutral axis wherever or
however it may be oriented for this
cross section I don't know how it will
be oriented right now but it will be
there I know that much I just want to
guarantee that the neutral axis will
pass through this particular origin and
because in the previous page I had just
proven that whether it is symmetric
bending of beams or an symmetric bending
of beams the neutral axis is guaranteed
to pass through the centroid so if I
choose the origin of my coordinate axis
y&z to be at the centroid the neutral
axis is guaranteed to pass through the
origin of this coordinate axis also so
what I will do is I will just denote the
neutral axis in this fashion
and what I will do is I will also orient
a new coordinate axis Z - along this
neutral axis
so maybe discolor
I'll call this LZ - which means that my
why - will be like this that follows
naturally so what is the motivation here
why am i doing all this so to get the
motivation will quickly take a look at
the previous page so here you note that
first I had this nice doubly symmetric
rectangular cross-section I knew that
the neutral axis would be oriented in
this fashion and what I did was to
orient or place my z axis along the
neutral axis and then I proved whatever
I wanted to prove but the key point to
extract from this simple or simpler case
of symmetric bending is that the z axis
here is lying along the neutral axis
which means that the Sigma xx that I
that I that are denoted here so this
these red arrows they denote the Sigma
xx here the Sigma xx is tensile in
nature it will be positive here it is
compressive in nature it is negative but
somehow I want to have my expression of
the flexure formula that will have a
direct connection with how the z axis is
oriented here so the key point to note
here is this the distribution of Sigma
xx here it is it is it is arranged in a
linear fashion about the z axis so what
I mean here is the very simple picture
which we are all accustomed to sing from
our undergraduate days where repeatedly
we used to draw diagrams like this that
we consider the cross section to be like
this
and we drew our stress distribution like
this
so you note that whatever I have drawn
just here is nothing but the front side
projection of this three-dimensional
picture I repeat
whatever I have drawn here is just the
front side projection of this more
complicated picture in 3d in 3d and you
note that this particular point is just
the front and view of the point which
denotes the neutral axis now I want to
import this idea directly to the case of
unsymmetric bending so going back to the
next page that is exactly what I have
done here I have first of all denoted
the neutral axis by this yellow color
dashed line I have then arranged for one
coordinate axis the Z dash to be
oriented like this the y dash follows
naturally from there so my hope is that
the the bending stress that will emerge
on this cross section the Sigma xx which
will be pointing either out of this
plane or into this plane will have some
sort of linear distribution and this is
very very important so I repeat it the
Sigma xx that will emerge from this
cross section and which will be denoted
by arrows pointing either into the plane
or out of the plane
those Sigma xx will have is some sort of
linear distribution about the Z dash
axis they will have some sort of linear
distribution about the Z dash axis why
is that hope having some sort of basis
it is having some sort of basis because
if the beam of which this cross section
is is a part if that beam is subjected
to pure bending then
forget about the y axis and the z axis
surely there will be some fibers of the
beam which will be in tension and some
fibers of the beam which will be in
compression and because we are
considering pure bending of beams it is
natural for us to expect that there will
be some flexure formula which will give
us a distribution for the or some sort
of answer for the Sigma xx right now we
don't know what that answer is but we
only have want to develop some kind of
intuitive or physical feel for that
Sigma xx and the physical field that we
want that we develop is that it will
have some kind of distribution about
this Z Z - axis so for example if the
part which is lying above the Z - axis
so let's say this part suppose if that
is in tension then the Sigma xx will be
pointing outward the arrows denoting
that that Sigma xx will be pointing out
of this and if the correspondingly this
lower part the part below the Z - axis
that will be in compression and the
arrows will be pointing into the into
the board here okay but that is only a
very qualitative picture how can we
develop a more quantitative picture for
this so for that what we have to do is a
little bit of algebra so first of all
what we will do is we will consider a
generic point on this cross section a
generic point which will be denoted
somewhere here so let's say
we take this point to be this may be
using different color so maybe somewhere
here now refer to the y axis and the z
axis this point this point that we have
just taken will have the coordinates as
Y comma Z I repeat the coordinate points
for this particular point that you have
chosen would be Y comma Z now how can we
write this in in terms of something
involving the Y - and the Z - okay so
now you will see the motivation for that
in a few minutes so what I want to do
first of all is I want to drop a
vertical from this point so
okay I've dropped a vertical from this
on the z-axis next I recognize that
refer to the Z dash axis this will have
a coordinate Z Y - head so this length
that I have just drawn this will be y -
now
this entire length I understand is why
this is refer to the Y z axis the red
colored axis and this one this one is
referred to the white dash Z dash axis
now what I will do is I will denote the
angle between Z dash and Y by beta so
this angle will be beta so if that is
beta this will also be beta this will
also be beta okay so what I want to do
now right now is to represent my Y in
terms of y dash and Z that can be easily
be done by considering first of all this
triangle so we are considering this
particular triangle first of all so my Y
will be composed of this length and then
this length so first of all to denote
this particular length
I will use my why - so that will be y
dash divided by sine beta
next for this little part for this
little part
I'll use my Z and that will be Z by tan
beta so what I'm doing here is just to
recognize that this much is my said so
this being beta this length will be
given by Z by tan beta the moment I have
this I can immediately write my y dash
as Y sine beta minus Z cos beta so we
multiply throughout by sine beta and we
transpose the the Z term to the to the
left hand side so we express the Y - in
terms of y&z so what is the use of that
well as I was mentioning earlier that we
have some sort of an intuition that the
Sigma xx the bending stresses would have
a linear distribution about the Z - axis
so we understand
it is very important to note that we are
considering pure bending and the bending
stresses Sigma xx will have a linear
distribution about the Z - axis
basically means that the Sigma xx will
have a linear distribution about the
neutral axis the z axis the z - axis is
actually coinciding with the neutral
axis here now although we understand
that this will be a linear distribution
but we don't exactly know what that form
of the linear distribution is so that is
now one of the big challenges here to
understand what that exact form is so to
keep things general what we'll do is
we'll just write it like this Sigma xx
is equal to K Y - so this particular
form KY - represents that the Sigma xx
is linear about the Z - axis what we
don't really know is what is the value
of this K but it is quite meaningless to
talk about the bending stresses without
first clearly denoting what the pure
bending is so what we'll do here is to
denote the pure bending in terms of a
bending moment so let's use let's use
this color
so we'll denote the bending moment but
but in terms of its components along the
z axis and the y axis so it's like this
let me draw online I will I'll I'll make
it disappear to reduce the clutter what
I want to do is I want to denote the
vector representation of my bending
moment in this fashion
so this kind of a vectorial
representation means that the bending
moment is and I wish I could actually
show you how I'm curling my fingers but
I'll try to describe it as best as I can
so what I'm trying to do here is I'm
trying
I have taken my right hand and I am
curling my fingers or I'm wrapping my
fingers about this about this orange
color double arrow so I'm curling my
fingers about about this stem about this
this line I'm curling my fingers around
this and I'm making my thumb point along
this one so when I do that that gives me
the sense of the bending moment but I
don't want to keep it like this what I
want to do is I want to resolve this in
terms of its components along the z axis
and the y axis so that'll be something
like this
this is not too bad so maybe I do not
have to make this orange-colored
double-arrow disappear so yeah but I
don't have to consider this so because I
have already taken the components I do
not have to consider this I will only
consider this component along the Z and
this component along the Y so this is MZ
and this is my so this is the loading
that is inducing the bending stresses
Sigma xx so now that we have this
picture in our hand what we can do is
try to express the MZ and the my using
the Sigma xx so let's see how we can do
this so while while we while you do this
we will first be using the y axis and
the z axis because of course the my is
oriented along Y and then Z is oriented
along Z so what we'll do is
we will first of all write down the
one-line expressions of MZ and my and
work on that in the next page so first
of all the MZ
now without worrying about the signs
what I need to write here is that in
terms of the bending stresses the MZ
will be brought about by this expression
so what i'm doing here is the sigma XX x
the DEA gives me the elemental force and
that elemental force multiplied by the y
here so sigma xx multiplied by the DEA
gives me the elemental force and that
multiplied by the moment and y gives me
the moment that's fine but i have to be
a little bit careful about the sign now
you see when i'm considering the m said
so this is my MZ and when i'm
considering this expression I understand
that the x-axis is pointing out of the
plane here so the orientation of my
x-axis is like this
so
so this denotes that the x-axis is
coming out of the plane so this is my
x-axis I have my X here now because my X
is pointing out of the plane by sign
convention my Sigma xx the positive
convention of say Sigma xx would also be
out of the plane now if I consider an
arrow representing the Sigma xx which is
anywhere on this cross section and I
take the the moment using the Y momentum
then and this is the part where I really
miss teaching live in class because I
wish I was able to show it by by using
my hand and my fingers by curling it in
the proper way but we'll try to make the
best of what we have so I take my Sigma
xx pointing out of the pointing out of
the cross section and Y is the moment
arm so the Y's Sigma xx here it will
give me a sense which is opposite to the
MZ so what I mean is this so let me see
if I can if I can make this picture
clearer somewhat clearer
in a three-dimensional sense so
so suppose I considered this to be my
beam
and
these are my y-axis and z-axis
my
MZ is pointing like this and
my Sigma xx is well the positive
convention means that this is my Sigma
xx this is my Sigma xx so anywhere that
I'm drawing it is following the sign
convention the positivity sign
convention so if I consider this kind of
the moment arm so this is my Y so you
understand that if I shift this arrow
here and take the vector product like
this this clockwise sense of the of the
turn from this moment arm to the Sigma
xx means that I would have to curl my
fingers of my right hand in such a
fashion that my thumb would be pointing
along the nigga's negative z-axis so
please mark my words carefully if I'm
taking the moment using my momentum Y
which is this and turning my fingers in
such a way turning the fingers of my
right hand in such a way that it's going
like this then the thumb of my right
hand is pointing in the negative z axis
which means the moment that
the moment that this thing by itself is
inducing is pointing along the negative
z axis which means that this is opposite
in sense to the given load the the given
bending moment MZ which means that there
must be a minus sign in front of this
now let's see if we can write down the
expression for my so again without
caring about the the sign convention let
me first write down in terms of the
Sigma xx so this time since I want to
denote the my I have to use my Z as the
moment arm and now I worry about the
sign convention so what I will do is
I'll I'll erase this thing here
and I'll read all the picture
to get a clear-cut idea about for mine
my okay so I understand that my my is
pointing like this so this is my my and
my Sigma xx just like before is it's
like this now
the moment arm for this about the y-axis
would be given by this said so this is
my Z now if I shift it like this and and
I I curl my fingers
can I call the fingers of my right hand
in this sense then the thumb of my right
hand would be pointing along the
positive Y axis I repeat for this Sigma
xx for for calculating the moment about
about the y axis so this is the y axis
I need my momentum to be this one so
this is the Z I shift this Z here and
then I curl my fingers from this moment
on into this Sigma X X such that the
thumb of my right hand is pointing along
the positive Y axis which means that I
do not need I do not need to put any
minus sign in front of this this is just
correct with positive sign so to make
things explicitly clear this is positive
so this expression on the right hand
side whatever the sense of the moment
here is this it is perfectly matching
with the given load the given bending
moment my so there is a plus sign here
so all that we have to do is to
substitute this expression of Sigma xx
equal to KY - here in this expression
and Sigma xx equal to KY - in this
expression and finally to express or to
substitute the expression of this Y -
from here Y sine beta minus Z cos beta
and
that will set set us up for some
algebraic simplifications okay so we'll
do that in the next page so the first
thing that we need to write is MZ is
equal to minus Sigma xx y da integration
okay so this is just a repetition of
what we wrote in the previous page
we substitute the expression of Sigma xx
so that is K Y -
and then we substitute the expression of
Y - so we check once more from the
previous page so this is the expression
we need Y sine beta minus Z cos beta
so this is K sine beta integration Y
square da minus K cos beta Y Z da which
means we can immediately rewrite this as
K sine beta isay minus K cos beta I
why's it next
for my
we have Sigma X X Z da
so just as before we substitute Sigma X
X is equal to KY - I'm not going to
write that again I'll directly write K Y
sine beta - set cos beta time said da
from which we have my is equal to K sine
beta iy said - K cos beta
why
we number our equations this first one
involving the - MZ as one and the second
one this M involving the my as two and
then we simply divide one by two to
quickly eliminate the unknown K so we'll
do that in the next page so we simply
divide one by two
so we take a look at the previous page
so this is K sine beta I said - K cos
beta iy said and this K will be
eliminated so this is basically just
sine beta I said - cos beta iy z
and in the denominator we have from
equation 2 sine beta iy z minus cos beta
iy
so what we do simply here is to divide
the right-hand side throughout by cos
beta to obtain tan beat up I said - iy
said divided by tan beta I why's it - iy
therefore if we cross multiply the terms
what we'll get is
- MZ dan betta I Y Zed + MZ iy is equal
to my tan vida I said - my iy said and
from this we can collect the terms
involving the tan beta so this term on
the left hand side we'll take it here
together with this one so that will give
us a tan beta common so we can quickly
write that tan beta
we'll be people to em said ìwhy plus my
eye Y Zed / let's see em said I Y Zed
and this term on the right hand side my
I said right my I said that's it okay so
what is this giving us you see
if we just take a quick look at our
initial picture so this horrible messy
looking picture and if we just focus on
this beta so what was this beta you see
this beta denoted the angle that the Z -
axis was making with the y axis but we
had chosen the set - axis to coincide
with the neutral axis therefore the beta
is the angle that the neutral axis is
making with our coordinate axis Y I
repeat beta is nothing but the angle
that the neutral axis is making with our
plane now you see the situation that we
are in it was our choice to orient the y
and the z axis in this particular
fashion so we are in complete control of
y&z we know about this what we didn't
know was the orientation of the neutral
axis so our our way of depicting the
neutral axis was rather an ignorant way
of denoting it basically because we did
not know the value of this beta but now
you see what has happened as a result of
all our manipulations over all our
algebraic manipulations
we have expressed the beta of course the
tan beta in terms of things which we
completely know about first of all we
know about the value of MZ because that
is given to us it is the Z component of
the bending moment that is given my is
the Y component of the bending moment
that is given so both MZ and my we very
much know furthermore because we have
complete knowledge about the cross
section about the geometry of the cross
section and we have actually chosen
ourselves the y axis and the z axis it
is very much within our power to
calculate the value of iy to calculate
the value of iy said and to calculate
the value of I said so all the things
that are present in the numerator and
all the things that are present in the
denominator are completely known to us
therefore as a result of our algebraic
manipulations we now are in position of
the knowledge of beta which we had
earlier not known therefore right now
what we have managed to do is find out
the orientation of the neutral axis
referred to one of our chosen coordinate
axis so now that we know about the
neutral axis about the orientation of
the neutral axis can we perhaps go one
step further and ask ourselves if it is
possible for us to find out an
expression for Sigma xx so let us take a
quick look back at our expression of
Sigma xx you see
our Sigma xx was here the thing which we
did not know about Sigma xx was K and
you see that we really did not know
about the Y - also because why - was
dependent on the orientation of Z - and
we really did not know about the
orientation of Z Zed - back then because
we did not know about the orientation of
neutral axis and the z - is coinciding
with the neutral axis but now because we
are in complete knowledge of the value
of beta in terms of known quantities so
we know about Z - which means we know
about why - so the only thing that we do
not know is K if we can find out K we
can find out the value of Sigma xx so
can we find out the value of K so let us
look at a different page here so if we
come back to equation one or equation 2
and substitute the expression of tan
beta here that can easily be done then
we can find out either from equation 1
or from Equation 2 the expression of K
so after finding out the expression of
beta in terms of tan beta we can find
out it is very much possible to find out
the expression for K the only difficulty
there is the fairly long algebraic
manipulations that we have to deal with
but in terms of of of the ease or the
simplicity of the steps nothing could be
simpler so all that we have to do and
I'm not going to write down this in
detail
I'm just going to outline the steps here
so let me go to the next step it's page
and write this down after we know about
beta
we can go to
equation one or equation two to find out
the expression for K once we do that
it's not very difficult to find out the
expression for Sigma xx so without going
into any of the fairly long algebraic
manipulations let me just give the
answer here for Sigma xx
so this is the answer for Sigma xx
so this is my x y iy Zed - Zed I said -
em said z iy said - weii why / this
entire thing / iy said square minus iy i
said now now a couple of points to note
here is that
well maybe three points first is that
this expression of Sigma xx is basically
just a very general version of the very
familiar flexure formula that we have
been studying all along during our
undergraduate days so this is a general
or a generalized flexure formula
which is applicable for unsymmetrical
bending and of course we can extract the
answers to some very to much simpler
case and statically from here for
example if we have the special case
where the entire bending moment is
oriented along the z axis so we don't
have the value of or we we have my equal
to zero and this becomes considerably
simpler a more important simple case is
when the y and the z axis are chosen to
be such that they are principal axis and
we have already learned earlier that in
such a case where the y and z axis are
principal axis the iy z will be equal to
zero and in that case this formula
becomes much much simpler so you can try
to find out
that is I've I said equal to 0 this will
become much simpler you can also try to
find out the well-known expression of
the flexure formula for that we learned
in our undergraduate days maybe for
example for a varies or a w symmetric
rectangular cross-section those are
fairly easy things to do so with this we
have more or less covered the important
things from the theory part of of
unsymmetrical bending the next topic
that we will discuss is shear Center
which will make use of of this
generalized flexure formula in some form
all right thank you very much